j'accueille aujourd'hui daniel wassef un
jeune amateur de soccer qu'on appelle
aussi football d'entre dans d'autres
endroits du monde
daniel wassef et de laval au québec il
vient d'inscrire son nom dans le livre
guinness des records dans la catégorie
saucats au top ce qui veut dire
tapotement d'orteils sur ballons bonjour
manière
bonjour à tous or daniel comment avez
vous décidé de battre ce record
racontez nous un peu c'est l'histoire de
ce record mais dans le fond tout a
débuté l année penser c'est que j'ai
fait dans un confinement
c'est que depuis les débuts c'est le
deuxième haut du confinement sais que
j'aurai pas de créativité en moi je vous
souhaitez dans ma rue puis vraiment
jaleo que nous mais j'avais beaucoup de
quatre mois dans ce cas le mail à moi ni
à 20 jours est arrivé dans ma rue j'ai
employé le pari de mon voisin et
d'enfants c'est que je me suis dit
pourquoi pas faire un truc spécial que
ça peut épater le monde genre gentil
pied le ballon dans le panier mais d'un
doux alors j'ai réussi à le faire lâche
at on appris genre presque 4 500 salles
frère et je les réussis à main filmant
la fin je voulais le transfèrement
record guinness mais ça n'a finalement
pas fonctionné parce que je devais payer
genre cinq dames en justice oublie ce
mais ensuite j'ai trouvé un autre qu'on
lit aussi que ce qui te plaît sata
patron d'arte ayant une minute je suis
encore parlent fort et j'ai décidé d'y
appliquer il vous est arrivé à combien
de tapotement donc votre record c'est de
combien par cet acadien et vous vous
avez réussi à faire cent cinquante et un
tapotement en une minute vous l'avez
enregistré et nous avons la vidéo vous
allez nous l'a commentée dans
c'est ça donc c'est ça c'est quand cette
façon que ça c'est exact ouais c'est
exactement comme ça que je les ai faites
et est ce que ça vous a demandé de la
préparation ou est ce que vous étiez
déjà prêts à faire ce jeu là oui ça m'a
demandé un peu plus d'exigences parce
que je devais pas juste ça fait la vidéo
mais je devais fournir des attestations
de témoins mais ils ont toléré sans
témoins parce que c'était sera un
complément puis j'avais pas le choix il
ne s'était pas de ma force à quai ils
ont approuvé sans témoin et comme ça a
été la réaction de votre entourage quand
ils ont vu que vous avez eu ce record il
était très léger très très étonné parce
qu'elle y croyant il pas au débat au
départ ils voulaient ils étaient un peu
sceptiques mais mon entourage mais le il
y avait certains qui croyais vraiment
que je peux réussir et loeb a ensuite je
me suis certain crois moi je peux
réussir et si j'étais sceptique en pas
un croyant et ce qui m'a emmené emmener
plus de courage et j'ai décidé de sujets
battre ce record
j'avais d'en faire deux jours pour pas
juste un personnel a formé près
saône-et-loire et du courage aux autres
à accomplir c'est quelque chose que moi
j'ai accompli puis ma mère leur de
giroussens trouveront sûrement encore tu
étais très étonné et très comptable
haut-parleurs il ya c'est à ses parents
à lui j'ai un fils qui a fait sa pige
j'encourage à vous on a construit le mot
le jeter hu au québec et au canada
le sport numéro 1 c'est le hockey et
comment vous vous êtes allés vers le
stockage est ce que c'est depuis votre
jeunesse commencé il ya 13 ans g j'étais
pas un fanatique de cinq heures avant ce
si j'avais 10 ans j'ai commencé à être
très pressés parce que parce qu est il
avait des bons tirs
il faisait des bons tirs au but face à
des mouvements genre avec les pieds d'un
même que son entreprise et on se dit je
prends ma saillie de puissance targon
fanatiques de structure engagées à
barcelone l'équipe
la seule egypte liverpool paris saint
germain c'était vraiment d euros qu
est-ce que vous intéresser aux rockets
oui en effet c'est contre le canadien de
montréal j'ai cru que mon frère puis
c'est avoir la langue donc chez vous
donc chez vous il ya le ok et le soccer
c'est ça les deux sports les plus
parfaites vous êtes né au canada vous
venez de parler de l'équipe d'égypte vos
parents viennent d'égypte oui mais pas
supporter un peu l'équipe que l'égyptien
anouar ahmed salah est ce que vous
suivez l'actualité de l'équipe nationale
d'égypte soca oui en effet j'aime ça
votre corps vous l'avez inscrits on met
2020 mais c'est un record qui a été
battu en août d'après ce que ce que j'ai
eu alors je pense que la personne qui
venait après vous allez arriver à 171 je
pense tapotement dites-moi est-ce que
vous pensez à faire d'autres records à
battre d'autres records
oui en effet cet amour d'israël et sur
cette année je le jeu rabattre accord
parce que je trouve que si j'ai eu du
potentiel à rabat
mon premier jeu en passes en 72 parce
que leur coach baptiste à 171 puis je me
suis dit gamache de la motivation et de
la persévérance
ça a été je parcours cela l'école sainte
et 10 elle-même mais dire que les gens
croient en moi je suis assurément je
bats encore lopy bond de 57 battre plus
longtemps de garder le ballon sur le
pied dans les ordres
écoutez je vous souhaite bonne chance
pour la suite de votre corps merci
daniel au hasard que je rappelle que
vous avez inscrit votre nom dans le
livre guinness des records dans la
catégorie tapotement porté sur un ballon
je vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
mais merci beaucoup à vous